the picket lines have been set and the
banners drawn the writers are on strike
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
move your Channel
[Music]
so yes from Midnight last night the
writers have gone on strike the Pens
have been put down no more scripts will
be completed and handed in but why has
this happened and how did we get to this
point and to be honest how is this now
going to affect some of the big projects
we've been looking forward to
wow we got to this point basically
because the writers have been felt a bit
gypped for quite a long time and the gap
between what The Writers Guild of
America have been asking for and what
the alliance of Studios have been
willing to offer has been vast but what
are the writers actually so upset about
well this basically comes down to pay
for a long time now the writers have had
their pay and they're something called
residuals which is kind of like
royalties money they get after the fact
of a show if a Show's very popular they
get a little bit more money that kind of
thing
that money has been squeezed and
squeezed and a lot of writers even top
showrunners have been on the minimum pay
something that's called scale in the
industry for quite some time in fact
there are more writers that work for
scale now than ever before there's also
some big technological reasons why the
writers aren't very happy and why they
feel they need a new contract to reflect
the new technological landscape we now
live one being streaming services
streaming services are not particularly
excited about releasing their actual
view in ours now we used to get viewing
figures now we get viewing hours how
many times a show is actually watched
now the rumor is that Netflix in
particular really really don't want
there to be greater transparency with
the writers and the rest of us about
those viewing hours they like to keep
those viewing figures quite quiet now
apparently the other streamer Services
aren't as bothered about this but
Netflix are determined that they're not
going to allow it now the writers really
want greater transparency because they
get residuals based on how much a show
is then actually watched they get like a
bit of extra money if a show does well
they don't have those numbers so they
are not confident that they're residuals
are actually accurate now most of us we
get paid on how many hours we do but if
part of our pay was based on success and
that bonus at the end of the year but
then the company didn't really tell us
how profitable the company had been they
just threw us a bonus and just said just
trust us you probably wouldn't go for it
you'd probably be wondering why you got
five grand one year and only 50 Quid the
next
that is basically what the writers have
been living with for quite some time
there's also another technological
Marvel AI now the writers say that if
they write a story that then gets put
into an AI and that AI then writes
another story based on that surely they
deserve some of those residuals because
the story that's then been created has
been written basically by them the
writers are saying surely if this story
is based on what I wrote don't I deserve
some of the residuals now this is a
slightly complicated problem
there are legal issues with this and so
the studios aren't really just being
complete not beds about this I suspect
they just don't quite know the answer
now what the Studios have suggested is
they will have annual meetings to
discuss the advancements in technology
and what can be done to support the
writers the writers are saying no we
want something agreed now
so on that part I don't think the
writers are being 100 Fair because I
think even though they are 100 right in
what they're saying there are actual
practical problems to what they're
talking about legally if that is a new
piece of material
how do you and then actually decide how
much of that should actually go back to
the writers
I can see that that's probably legally a
Minefield but one thing we can 100 all
agree on is pay as part of this contract
between the wga and the alliance of
Studios there is a minimum pay agreement
they call it working for scale as I
mentioned earlier now lots and lots of
writers unfortunately I have to work for
the scale even some showrunners if you
think you're the boss and you're still
working for minimum pay that sucks but
not just this there's been a big problem
with job security Now The Writers Guild
of America want the studios to start
putting the writers on longer contracts
they want the contracts to show that if
they work on an episodic TV show say I
don't know the rookie that runs for six
or eight months they want the writers to
get a contract for that period they want
them to have some job security while the
show they're working on is running
now the studios don't want to do that
and they tend to run on weekly contracts
you at your work how happy would you be
to stay on a weekly contract
I'm not sure you would
on some comedy and variety shows they
only get daily rates which is basically
means you get paid for that day you're
in
if you don't work tomorrow you don't
work tomorrow again none of us would
live like that we just wouldn't we just
want at least some job security right
and not to be only earning the absolute
minimum just to show the massive
difference between what The Writers
Guild of America are asking for and what
the studios are suggesting The Writers
Guild of America's proposal would be
basically worth around 429 million
dollars the council proposal by the
studios was only worth 86 million
dollars and half of that 86 million
dollars was an increase in the scale so
an increase in that minimum wages
that is a massive difference and you can
really understand why the wga feel like
they're hitting their heads against the
brick wall but how will the strike
affect some of those big projects that
we know and love and a desperately
waiting to get green lit like Babylon 5
the new Orville series and Stargate
the problem is we don't know
we have no idea how long this strike
will last and the room is actually that
a lot of the studios are okay with this
strike and even want it do persist they
want to be able to cancel certain
projects and save face and basically
blame the writers for it if that is true
even on any level this strike could go
on for a while last time it went on for
a hundred days now on streamer Services
we may not quite notice it so much
because at the end of the day the
writing for any new streaming project is
done and then the film is done then it
gets released but things that are on a
network that are being produced right
now like The Late Late Show and things
like this things that are written on the
day and then produced and put out
they're all pretty much canceled for the
moment and the Networks you're really
going to see this effect
but the streaming services
they feel like they can wait at the end
of the day they've got scripts for stuff
and they're going to film it they'll be
a bit of a gap but they're probably not
that bothered and they're willing to let
the writers go on strike and then get a
deal that's a lot closer to the 86
million dollars than it is to the 429
million dollars the WG actually want
they're also I suspect desperately
trying to keep hold of their anonymity
and not wanting to have any sort of
major transparency when it comes to
viewing numbers so we don't really know
what's going to happen
but I'll keep following the story and
I'll let you know as soon as I know
anything but guys get to the comments
tell me what you think of the wga right
to strike they just don't want to earn
minimum pay and
who does
the concert tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and if you could go over to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack you
get to see most of our new videos first
and for a small contribution each month
that really helps the channel out you
get to see them without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]